you're watching white is that we've got
me this week who came out on top with
the Pocket lint gadget Awards 2016 while
we think about the year in gadgets I
mull over what went wrong for some and
final fantasy returns finally hello and
welcome to a special from the e Pocket
lint gadget Awards in London tonight's
winners have been decided by you the
industry and a panel of judges 2016 has
been the year that virtual reality
became well reality oculus HTC and Sony
launched their much awaited headsets
with PlayStation VR being chosen as the
best of the bunch this week it's a
celebration of all things tech the
annual Pocket lint award selects the
year's best gadgets through a
combination of expert judging and public
votes Sony picked up another two honors
on the night for Best TV and best
headphones
[Music]
while Apple claimed three Awards as well
for laptop tablet and SmartWatch but it
missed out on the prize for best
smartphone that went to Samsung for the
s7 edge the South Korean companies had a
turbulent year with the Galaxy Note 7
being discontinued after a series of
battery fires they'll be hoping
recognition like this will help them get
back on track the s7 actually launched
[Music]
we're continuing to innovate and really
deliver products that consumers won and
this is goes a long way to continuing
their job Alexa how many tablespoons are
in 3/4 cup 3/4 cups is 12 tablespoons
Amazon won the big prize products of the
year for the echo Bluetooth speaker
features a voice controlled personal
assistant called Alexa she can play
music on request help with shopping
lists and recipes and give you weather
updates so is the age of the smart home
finally upon us we think voice is the
future we think is the most natural
interface to someone we all use every
day and the one that we're all training
to you since birth
we think it's we've got a fundamentally
changed the way that people interact
with technology and I think this is just
a start it's still very very early and
gaming was celebrated too with Naughty
Dog's uncharted for winning best title
it brought off competition from the
smartphone craze of the summer Pokemon
go so what's in store for next year's
awards 2017 we also mark the 10th year
since Apple unveiled the very first
iPhone so we should expect the iPhone 8
or some people are predicting we might
even go straight to the iPhone 10 which
unlikely but we'll say it will probably
have to have a lot of new features to
convince people to keep buying this
larger sort of formed iPhone larger
screens as the year draws to a close
awards ceremonies like these become more
frequent and with Christmas around the
corner tech companies will be hoping
that the accolades will translate into
sales Chris Craig and Sky News
stay with us still to come we've seen
who's celebrated a good year in gadgets
but who's had the worst are we talking
to another of the judges right after a
roundup of this week's tech news a drone
code has been set up to help avoid
collisions with planes it comes after a
series of min misses involving UAVs and
aircraft the Civil Aviation Authority
which published the new code of conduct
says they've been 58 close calls in the
last 12 months Instagram is the latest
social media giant to get into live
video a new feature lets users
broadcaster followers but they can only
be viewed while they're happening then
they disappear Facebook which owns
Instagram introduced live video
streaming earlier this year while
Twitter bought a similar service
periscope in 2015
the UK's travel website Skyscanner is
being snapped up by China's sea trip
calm when a deal worth 1.4 billion
pounds the enemy based company lets
users compare prices when searching for
flights hotels and rental cars and the
founder of Twitter had his own account
temporarily suspended this week Jack
Dorsey said it happened because of an
internal mistake his accounts now up and
running again
time to get training Pokemon is back but
first now let's have a chat to one of my
fellow judges Victoria Williston from
Wired UK Vicki we voted for who we
thought were the best who do you think's
had the toughest year I'm gonna have to
say Samsung poor world Samsung it
started so well for so long I mean
obviously Samsung some huge amounts of
handsets but they're always compared to
Apple they're always looking for that
iPhone killer and I really felt they
found it with the galaxy note 7 and then
within about a week or so people getting
their hands on it battery start sort of
blowing up and setting on fire and
causing people huge injuries so how do
they come back from that now first thing
we need to find out what the cause was I
think I don't even know if Samsung know
exactly why these phones are having one
of these problems but I think what they
need to do now is just sort of draw a
line under this they need to say look
they've already apologized I sent this
open letter to their customers and they
say look we promise to do better what
they've done really well is they faced
up to it they haven't just sort of shied
away from it there every time they've
had an earnings call or they've had
something they've discussed it and I
think that's what they need to just
carry on doing is to make the point that
look we are really sorry we did have
this problem but going forward we're
gonna learn from it and tonight of
course is all about celebrating and
gadgets looking ahead to 2017 what
trends do you think we're gonna see I
actually think the voice-activated home
personal speakers they're gonna be quite
big in 2017 Alexa play rock music as an
echo and Alexa come out this year and
then Google's home is going to come out
next year and I think that's going to be
the big trend as where people start
moving away from their mobile devices
and having this one device in their home
it's just me control everything now it's
been ten years in the making but the
latest installment of final fantasy is
finally here but does it deliver here's
Luci final fantasy 15 is definitely the
big release it was announced 10 whole
years ago so anticipation is very high
my son my inner the key to our attention
it's a Japanese role-playing game series
and in this version Final Fantasy 15 you
are playing as like the crown prince of
a leading kingdom of Lucis and a
neighboring Kingdom called Niffleheim
come in and they steal the basically the
key to your kingdoms power and you think
that all your family are dead and it's
basically you and your trusted
bodyguards and your advisors you go on
this kind of road trip and you have to
basically take back what's yours and
it's a big mix of role-playing elements
so there's obviously an experienced
leveling system there's a big huge open
world to explore you get to drive around
you get to ride on these adorable kind
of bird horse things called chocobos
which are big mainstay in Final Fantasy
and this is grand huge story full of
magic and intrigue and it has been a
long ten years but it's finally out on
Tuesday for Xbox one and ps4
2016 is the year of pokemons 20th
anniversary so of course they're gonna
have a big installment and this year
we've got Pokemon Sun and Moon it's the
core game that we know and love you know
you are a pokemon trainer and you have
to go around this this land this time
it's inspired by Hawaii just finite it's
quite tropical and you have to collect
these pocket monsters as it translates
to in Japanese but it's a sort of saw
monsters you capture them in your
pokeball you take them around you train
them you battle them against other
trainers and by doing that you kind of
progress through the story and your
ultimate goal is to defeat the nefarious
team skull but you know Pokemon Sun and
Moon it's very exciting there's new
Pokemon if you train your Pokemon enough
they evolve into different forms and a
mega evolution it's like an even more
powerful and awesome form that they can
go into not all the Pokemon are
available in Sun and not that all of
them are available moon there's
different Pokemon in each one so it's a
great way for you to meet your friends
exchange your 3ds friend codes and
exchange Pokemon and hopefully catch
them all planet coaster is a kind of
simulation game building game where you
create your own theme park you make your
own ride kind of like if you played
rollercoaster take you in theme park
worlds you basically understand what
planet coaster is it is a game where
you've got you know you can there's
various modes in it so there's like a
career mode where you can try and build
your own successful park it's really
cool and if you're looking for a game
that you can just sort of relax in tune
you've got a PC then I would definitely
recommend you check out planet coaster
it's a lot of fun and it's very
rewarding
well that's it for this week but if you
enjoyed watching swype you can actually
watch any of our episodes in our YouTube
playlist just type in sky this way and
you can stay up to date with all the
latest tech stories throughout the week
sky news on mobile tablet catch up sky
cute and snapchat we'll be back next
week hope you can join us then bye bye
you
[Music]